linking of hands across three major
subway routes Hong Kong human chains up
to ten kilometers long there are echoes
here of the famous Baltic way exactly
thirty years ago a human chain against
Soviet rule in Eastern Europe three
decades on pro-democracy campaigners in
Hong Kong are also calling for the
international hand of friendship
demonstrations began in June over plans
for a law allowing the extradition of
criminal suspects to mainland China
demands have now grown many here believe
Beijing is encroaching on the freedoms
they hold dear the government what a
dialogue so so we think dialogue and a
compromise and a consensus should be the
only way out violence certainly it's not
the way of solving the problems which
every society has although recent
protests have been peaceful they are
prepared for more tear gas and also want
to hide their faces from the authorities
Chinese troops in Shenzhen on Hong
Kong's border are a constant reminder
Beijing is prepared to step in the
position of the central government is
very clear that if the situation
continues to this the digit in
degenerate and it becomes uncontrollable
for the Hong Kong SAR government the
central government will not sit on its
hands
obviously the Chinese government and the
Hong Kong government will find a proper
solution to the issue that is to deal
with the arrest swiftly quilled
arrest swiftly there is a fear of
reprisal a British Consulate employee in
Hong Kong Simon Cheng has been detained
in China for two weeks after trying to
return from a business trip he's a
Chinese citizen and he violated he broke
the public security law on the Chinese
mainland I don't have all the specifics
but the information we have is a
violated public security law and was
dealt with according to the law
protesters are desperate not to repeat
the failure of the twin
14 pro-democracy umbrella movement as
the new academic year begins in
September
students are calling from mass walkouts
with hints the unrest will continue
until it's stopped by force jonathan
Sammy's sky me